David should Bernie or Warren if they
are the nominees consider a more
centrist or a more progressive running
mate so when picking a running mate
often there are three factors that are
brought up ideology of the running mate
the what region of the country they are
from and their demographic sort of
characteristics ideology would be fewer
progressive do you go with another
progressive or do you go with like a
centrist or more of more moderate region
would be if you are like Bernie and
Warren from the Northeast Warren you
know talks about being from Oklahoma or
whatever but Jesus Massachusetts senator
you're a northeast elected official do
you go with another Lord northeast
elected official or like a West Coast
elected official which is similar or do
you try to get someone from the Midwest
or from the south or something like that
and then demographics if you are for
example seventy years of age or older
as both Bernie I believe Warren seventy
right and Bernie's older than that do
you go with a younger candidate or do
you go with someone else who is in their
70s if you are a man do you go with a
woman if you are white do you go with
someone who's not white so on and so
forth it's very appealing to try to
round out the ticket with someone who is
different but complements what you bring
so if you're a progressive bring a
moderate so that you bring moderates
into the ticket if you are from the
Northeast bring someone from somewhere
else so that you have more Geographic
geographically diverse background if you
are whatever racial demographic
religious demographic gender age
whatever you bring someone different to
appeal to different different people I
actually think that it's far simpler
than this you need a vice president who
is not a going to become the story and
be make any gas Mike Pence was perfect
for Donald Trump in this sense he stayed
completely out of the way who remembers
anything that Mike Pence did I have no
recollection of the debate that Mike
Pence had with Tim Kaine by the way we
could talk about the choice of Tim Kaine
as maybe not a good one but that's for
another story pencil is like a statue
whenever Trump talked Pence is
completely motionless the guy knows how
to blend into the back
if Donald Trump ends up impeached and
convicted maybe Mike Pence will end up
as President of the United States and
that's priority number one someone who's
not going to get in the way or do gaffes
or whatever in addition to that if you
can find someone that is a compliment
ideologically regionally or
demographically that also helps that was
also pence pence an evangelical
conservative very different than Trump a
more pro-business Republican regionally
Trump from New York City pence from
Indiana demographically okay I mean
they're both just white dudes so maybe
maybe there's less about that but it
worked so as crazy as it is the model
for who to choose is what Donald Trump
did with Mike Pence someone who won't
get in the way or become the story or
gaffe in a way that would hurt you or or
could cost you the election and if
there's some benefit to some of the
other characteristics all the better I
would go away from making the primary
choice about progressive candidate
should have a progressive running mate
and we're going all in on progressivism
or progressive candidate should have a
moderate running mate so that you can
appeal to both moderates and
progressives this is going to be a
turnout election this is going to be an
election of how do they face up against
Donald Trump particularly during the
debates and with the nicknames and
everything else that's where I would
prioritize my thinking and if you get
some benefit along the other paths I
ideology ideologically complementary
geographically got complementary or
demographically complementary all the
better let me know what you think we've
got a great bonus show for you today
Pat's bonus show on Friday join
pakman.com sign up for a membership and
get instant access to the bonus show